the 1965 sci-fi novel dune is enduring
for a lot of reasons it takes place in a
world rife with political intrigue and
fearsome spycraft where trust is just as
valuable as the spice found on the
planet arrakis that makes dune fertile
ground for the 4x approach to strategy
games shiro games dune spice wars tries
to leverage those multitudes to give
players a whole lot more to keep track
of than just the enemy soldiers amassing
on your borders
we played several hours of the early
access version of dune spice wars ahead
of its release which gives a pretty
solid although still somewhat incomplete
look at the game and how it works
battling for arrakis requires some
military might but not nearly as much as
you might think in fact the game is
designed so that standing armies stay
small and battles rarely rise above
momentary skirmishes even if you want a
military victory over your opponents
conquering the harsh planet of arrakis
is often easier than governing it if
you're unfamiliar with it the story of
dune both the novel and its movie
adaptations including the newest
released in 2021 are set in the distant
future in a galaxy spanning feudalistic
society not too different from that of
say medieval europe there are great
houses led by dukes and barons who make
up a government called the lance rad
under an empire there are also various
commercial enterprises like the chome
company and the spacers guild at the
center of it all is arrakis otherwise
known as dune which is the only place in
the universe where a very special drug
called melange or spice can be found the
spice is incredibly valuable eating it
grants long life greater amounts bestow
some special abilities like future sight
and without it timely interstellar space
travel is impossible thus whoever
controls the spice controls the universe
in spice wars you're trying to be the
person who controls the spice and it is
a lot of trouble you pick from one of
four factions the two main great houses
from dune atreides and harkonnen the
smugglers eking out a living on the
fringes of arrakis or the native fremen
each faction has its own strengths and
weaknesses based on their worldview as
well as their own special kinds of units
and buildings but everyone's goals are
the same find and mine the spice use it
to gain wealth and take over arrakis as
quickly as possible i spent most of my
time playing as the fremen the hardy
desert dwellers who've appeared in past
dune games but haven't really been
playable as a faction before the freeman
enjoys some nice benefits over the other
factions because they're generally best
equipped to survive on arrakis a planet
that is constantly trying to kill you as
you first start exploring arrakis in
search of spice fields and other
exploitable resources the inhospitable
world itself is your primary enemy
military units struggle to survive
outside of territory you control which
you can expand by capturing the village
that occupies each zone the longer you
travel outside of your empire the more
your unit's supply decreases and once it
runs out their health drops basically
simulating dying of thirst the landscape
of arrakis then actually undercuts open
warfare in a lot of cases you can't just
march a big band of troops around the
deep desert killing anyone who gets in
your way because your army will die
before you get there but the fremen
generally seem like the faction with the
biggest military advantage knowing the
desert means they're better equipped to
survive there they're good at
camouflaging themselves to escape
dangerous situations or set ambushes and
they can summon sand worms for speedy
long range travel while other factions
have to build airfields and launch
shuttles the other factions have their
upshots too however each tends to
specialize in a particular sector of the
game the freemen are best at desert
warfare the scheming harkonnen get
benefits in spying the reputable
atreides are adept politicians and the
well-connected smugglers gain economic
bonuses in addition to unique units for
each faction they also have their own
special traits for instance the atreides
player can capture villages through
diplomacy rather than bloodshed which
means they don't have to spend time
rebuilding everything they've destroyed
the harkonnen meanwhile have the ability
to brutalize their people instantly
increasing production through fear and
speaking of sand worms they're another
constant issue as you move around
arrakis although not nearly as much as
in the book the worms show up
occasionally mostly when you're in the
middle of a battle giving you a short
period to get away from the dangerous
warm sign before a huge maw opens up and
swallows your units when you're not
contending with worms or just dying of
exposure in the desert there are
occasionally massive sandstorms that can
wipe out your armies
even if they just pass through your
territory sandstorms grind production to
a halt briefly flooring your economy in
affected towns in ways that can be
devastating if you're just scraping by
or executing a plan for construction or
expansion
water of course is also essential to
survival making it a resource you have
to be constantly attending to any units
you control require water the towns you
capture require water and trading with
the hidden independent fremont villages
called sieges requires water it can also
be transformed into wealth when it's in
abundance or drive your people to
rebellion when it runs out water is
mostly gathered by building wind
catchers near your towns but one segment
of the map the polar sink offers a ton
of the resource in the form of arrakis's
polar ice cap once you find it you want
to be the person to capture it as
managing water can be a major
distraction throughout the game no
resource is more central than spice
although you don't actually really use
it finding and mining spice gives you a
resource you can sell for solari the
currency of the realm and dune to pay
for everything else but every month or
so the empire extracts its tax in spice
and if you want to maintain good
standing with the lance rad key for
political machinations you'll want to
keep yourself paid up with spice you're
not stockpiling for later or to pay the
tax man you can instantly trade for
solari so you're not really as concerned
with having spice as much as ensuring
that the spice is flowing you'll manage
it with a meter that determines how much
spice you stockpile and how much you
convert for cash and so the idea is to
keep the meter balanced to pay salary
upkeep costs on all your stuff and your
spice tax bill at the end of the month
keeping all those plates spinning is
essential in spice wars and you spend so
much time just keeping your society from
sinking into the desert that the wars in
spice wars are actually pretty small
scale but that feels like it's in
keeping with the story told in dune it's
not about huge armies and massive
artillery leveling cities most of the
time anyway but about guerrilla fights
and mastering the desert to best your
opponents as the fremen the major
advantage i had was quickly getting my
forces into advantageous positions with
sand worms and going on the offensive
thanks to my greater ability to survive
in the desert you need to do a decent
job of keeping an eye on your forces
though since battles and armies are
generally pretty small there's room for
the game to put some emphasis on
managing the placement of your forces
like keeping ranged teams out of harm's
way or on high ground
this is a 4x game and economics and
warfare only make up part of the game
the other things you need to worry about
are politics and spycraft you need to
build at least a nascent network of
spies because elements like the chome
company and the lance red are big
influences on ariken life even if you
don't interact with those factions
directly having someone inside their
ranks helps you wield influence on them
spying also has a more practical purpose
on the ground with your spies in place
you can ready operations that give you
an edge when your forces have to throw
down with hearkening goons or atreides
troopers one operation brings emergency
supplies to your fighters to regenerate
their health while another sabotages
enemy gear to weaken their forces
operations vary in effect though and
they come with the cost of potentially
exposing your spies to the enemy at key
moments in the game i played the longest
though my toughest foe wasn't the war
machine of the other factions the secret
meddling of assassins or the hostility
of arrakis itself one of the main and
most straightforward means of victory to
pursue in spice wars is a hegemony win
with hegemony being a score that
measures your overall control of arrakis
and that dishes out major bonuses at
specific milestones my fremont empire
was a powerful one and with more or less
unmatched military might we spread
across much of the desert eliminating
the smuggler faction by surrounding it
and slowly strangling it of resources i
next laid into the harkonnen who were
quickly creeping toward the score needed
to win sacking and liberating their
towns in the same strangle maneuver
unfortunately i neglected the lance rat
council where votes occur every so often
these mostly concern edicts that can
adjust the economy levy fines and taxes
and speed or slow growth but they also
see factions vying for control of key
government interests the freemen aren't
actually in the landsrad so without any
actual votes of my own i could only
spend influence a resource you gain
through statecraft goals and buildings
which represent trying to get other
people to do what you want with enough
votes influence and diplomacy though you
can get yourself elected to be arrakis
governor and that's how the harkenin
ultimately won my game
even as i was ripping through their
military liberating their villages and
stealing their resources watching the
evil harken and baron game the system to
take control of the planet through guile
felt extremely doomed i have to say the
only thing better would have been if his
spies had somehow assassinated me a
thing that apparently can happen as well
dune spice wars releases in steam early
access on april 26th and from the sounds
of things shiro games intends to add
more factions and other elements in the
future including multiplayer the battle
to control the spice sounds like it's
going to get even more complex and
intense but for now dune spice wars
scratches that 4x itch while also
capturing the essential lethality of the
planet and the universe on which it's
based